[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans point
de vue rabbit vous retrouvez ce soir en
compagnie de richard bride bonsoir on
sent que vous êtes le premier adjoint
socialiste à la mairie du 12e
arrondissement de paris il est aussi co
directeur de l'observatoire sport et
sociétés à la fondation jean jaurès puis
jérôme sainte-marie là aussi bon soir
jérôme vous êtes sondeurs politologues
vous avez fondé la société l'étude pôle
inbox est votre dernier livre bloc
contre bloc la dynamique du maquereau
nisme est publié aux éditions du cerf et
bien le maquereau nisme parlons-en
justement je propose de consacrer toute
notre émission à une interview
importante du président de la république
dans zadig le trimestriel édité par
l'ancien directeur du monde eric
fottorino interview importantes d'abord
parce qu'elle fait dix-huit pages et je
remercie nos invités d'avoir pris la
peine de se plonger dedans et puis parce
que à un an des élections
présidentielles on y retrouve très
probablement des thèmes qui pourront
être présents lors de la prochaine
campagne
la preuve le premier message peut être
délivrée par le prochain à un public
c'est un message d'optimisme il parle de
la pandémie et il compare cette crise
sanitaire
à la fin du moyen âge et comme chacun
sait après le moyen-âge il ya la
renaissance on ne sait pas si emmanuel
macron et le nouveau françois 1er mai en
tout cas il est très optimiste il pense
que la france a tous les atouts pour
sortir de cette crise
jérôme sainte marie ce discours très
volontariste est très positif tranche
avec ce qu'on entend parfois ses terres
qu on a une crise sociale devant nous
que les que les français vous en vouloir
emmanuel macron est ce que vous pensez
qu'il est dans le déni ou est-ce que
c'est lui qui a raison
je pense qu'en partie il aura raison
tout simplement parce que les gens
souffrent on se sentira tant soit peu
libéré donné bibere dans leur vie
quotidienne
on peut d'ailleurs interprété des
résultats de popularité qui ne sont pas
mauvais pour emmanuel macron et son
premier ministre il ya une augmentation
significative dans le dernier bébé je
crois et qui apparemment est imputable
en tout cas c'est le commentaire qu'on
fait l'institut est imputable plutôt à
od confinement est beaucoup plus grande
on va regarder si vous
et bien la courbe de popularité des
manuels mâcon depuis le début de la
pandémie c'est à dire en fait depuis
janvier 2020 il est à 30% d'opinions
favorables ça c'est une c'est la cote
ifop
donc encore un peu abîmée par la crise
et gilet jaune il est aujourd'hui à 40%
donc a priori la traverser sans encombre
mais pardon je vous ai coupé la parole
vous la redonne voilà donc il y aura un
effet un gain
conjoncturelle proment assez limitée
dans le temps
lier tout simplement au fait que les
vents seront des confiné il y aura
peut-être quelque chose de plus
intéressant c'est les propos de bruno le
maire je crois c'est à dire un regain de
l'activité économique et des chiffres de
croissance c'est assez mécanique puisque
l'activité a été gelé pendant des mois
et des mois
forcément les commerces rouvrent etc et
il pourrait y avoir dans six mois en
disant regardez c'est fantastique les
gens se remettent à dépenser et de fête
rassemble d'achat ont été différées et
se produiront donc on aura dans les rues
des grandes villes et ses mains de
partout on aura évidemment une
impression d'une activité qui repart ça
n'effacera pas bien sûr les dettes
accumulées ça n'effacera pas notamment
le remboursement pour beaucoup de chefs
d'entreprises du prêt garanti par l'état
qui a été différé de remboursement était
différent d'un homme et qui va arriver
en mars avril à échéance et bien sûr les
dégâts structurels causé à l'économie
française ne devrait pas être compensé
mais à court terme je pense que le
discours positif du président de la
république trouvera des débuts de
lustration ce qui est intéressant dans
cette interview et sarrebruck c'est que
le président prend prendre la distance
il n'est pas dans l'analyse des chiffres
immédiat il parle plutôt d'un nouvel
élan d'une france qui a qui a confiance
en elle même tout ça est parfois un peu
lyrique comme comme souvent avec le
président est ce que ça vous a convaincu
ce discours ça n'a pas forcément
convaincu mais par contre je trouve que
c'est un discours qui épouse très bien
l'air du temps celui de déconfinement on
est dans un moment d'euphorie dans un
moment on a envie aussi tourné une page
de se lancer dans quelque chose d'autre
et il se pose aussi comme celui qui
implémentent déjà une vision un peu
optimiste d'un avenir qui serait pas du
tout un avenir rance un avenir replié un
avenir un peu noir est un peu sombre
voilà il est très optimiste et
effectivement ça correspond ça
correspond à la 5 à la séquence et vous
disiez très bien c'est aussi aujourd'hui
des éléments de l'analyse à la fois
économique et social économique parce
qu'on a vu
que cette crise pour le moment elle a
plutôt voilà laisser un haut niveau
d'investissement elle a laissé des
trésoreries qui sont quand même pas trop
amputer dans les entreprises elles
donnent l'impression avec les plans qui
vont être ceux de la relance en amérique
que quelque chose peut encore se
produire en termes de relance de
croissance
bref ya des signes plutôt optimiste et
je pense que le président se heurtent
sur cet optimisme du moment et ça
s'inscrit bien cette séquence de
l'interview dans cette volonté du moment
de passer cette étape de la pandémie
d'aller vers autre chose
alors bien évidemment il ya quand même
des signes d'inquiétude parce qu'on ne
peut pas dire que l'avenir soit
forcément déjà décidé et que on sait par
exemple ce qui se passera en septembre
prochain ou en janvier prochain
peut-être qu'on aura des entreprises qui
réussiront moins bien que d'autres on
sait que certains secteurs marche bien
mais d'autres marchent moins bien par
exemple l'hôtellerie la restauration la
des grosses questions par exemple sur la
confiance dans l'avenir
les français sont quand même toujours un
peu réticent et un peu méfiant donc on a
quand même des signes d'inquiétude on
sait aussi que les perspectives en
termes de consommation ou pal de ce
qu'on appelle les parigots vide et si
elle reste c'est 160 milliards accumulés
s'il reste en gros dans un moment
d'epargne c'est pas la même chose que si
on les consomme et que l'impact sur
l'emploi pourrait aussi avoir des
conséquences donc plus la réforme de
l'assurance chômage etc
on a des signaux d'inquiétude à côté de
ce moment d'euphorie donc c'est un petit
peu et ce que le temps du déconfinement
sera le temps d'une croissance durable
et le temps d'un avenir un peu plus
confiants pour les français aujourd'hui
c'est quand même une question mais le
président pose sa marque qui est celui
de l'optimisme et du passage du
moyen-âge peut-être à la renaissance
mais pourquoi pas en tout cas ce qu'il
veut dire c'est qu'on va vers des temps
meilleurs et ce sera je crois un de ses
discours qui commence à installer de la
campagne oui je crois qu'effectivement
c'est une interview qui est très écrite
mais qu'ils interviewent de quelqu'un
qui est en campagne qui vont en parler
qui veut nous montrer à travers sa
géographie notamment à quel point il
aime la france c'est important mais
c'est assez amusant d'ailleurs d'autres
d'en être arrivé là mais pourquoi pas
ensuite vous plaît
et il retrouve les mêmes lacroix en fin
d'interview on retrouve ce qui avait été
sa singularité et sa force durant la
campagne de 2010 est alors que la
plupart des politiques des candidats
sinon tous présentés les problèmes de la
france et les solutions mais à des
problèmes lui avait un discours d'un
optimisme tout à fait confondant est
tout à fait originale c'était un
discours à la fois d'énergie et surtout
c'était très très positif c'est là il
recommence il recommence effectivement
avec ce discourt très optimiste ce qui
est coloré maintenant d'une manière un
peu différente que qu'à l'époque c'est
que c'est le discours positif et
optimiste de quelqu'un qui doit aussi
assumer un bidon et parmi les
inquiétudes des français
on a signalé 7 des actifs mais on peut
signaler tout celle des contribuables
puisque quand même l'argent magic a
coulé à flot durant des mois et des mois
tout de façon totalement contradictoire
par rapport au discours des manuels
macron au discours traditionnel des
économistes tenue juste avant le
confinement et là on nous dit bah
finalement c'est pas grave quoi c'est
pas grave on a dépensé des montagnes des
milliards d'euros aux dizaines de
milliards d'euros
c'est pas grave en fait ça repart et
c'est face au maître fantastique après
moyen âge vient la renaissance et
effectivement nous avons alors vous
pensez à françois 1er moi je vais penser
à mes 10 610 gorille dans l'interview
protecteur des arts n'est ce pas et
prince de machiavel également d'apposer
la question à nos internautes sur
twitter emmanuel macron est il trop
confiants concernant la sortie de crise
sanitaire vous êtes 60 % à considérer
que oui majorité forte mais pas
complètement écrasante non plus quelques
réactions celle de 100 cloud sur youtube
il fait ça pour avoir des voix pour son
parti aux élections régionales n'est sur
twitter qui nous dit c'est la sagesse en
doute il est impossible de répondre tout
de suite à cette question françois sur
youtube est sévère les annonces faites
par ce gouvernement ont été un fiasco
il soit par des événements difficilement
prévisibles soit par un manque de
projection certain françois fait sans
doute allusion aux annonces concernant
la gestion de la pandémie
nous pouvons toutes et tous félicité les
deux gouvernements macron pour
l'endurance de la sécurité sanitaire
engagé en france nous dit christian sur
le site du figaro depuis babineau
toujours sur lefigaro.fr
les français sont confiants à la proche
de l'été mais outre la communication des
manuels macron le déconfite mans est
très progressif
vous faisiez allusion jérôme
sainte-marie à au long développement du
précédent république sur la géographie
de notre pays c'est intéressant alors
peut-être qu'on lui a fait des fiches
mais il ya notamment une description de
l'impact de la désindustrialisation sur
la région d'amiens et tout ça est quand
même assez précis alors il nous parle
des endroits qu'ils aiment bien alors il
parle de saint-cirq-lapopie terrain
vidal dans le lot un peu village de
carte postale aussi de la seine saint
denis en expliquant que timbaut
laboratoire de la france de demain et
10,6 si la france a des difficultés pour
pour repartir
ça n'est pas parce que il y aurait trop
de bureaucratie mais c'est parce qu'il
ya trop de corporatisme des intérêts en
présence qui sont là et qui ne veulent
pas bouger et il fait allusion un peu
plus loin dans l'interview à la réforme
de l'ena est ce que vous croyez et sabri
que c'est le bon moment pour recommencer
à faire bouger la société
le président veut par exemple réformer
les retraites ou l'assurance chômage ou
est-ce que la france le contraire
fragilisé par par deux entre qu'ovide un
an et demi en tout cas non mais là
encore je crois que c'est le président
qui veut rester dans l'image qu'il a
donnée de lui à la fois sur l'optimisme
mais aussi sur le président de la
réforme sur le présent qui fait bouger
les choses
le problème c'est qu'il les a fait
jusqu'à présent bouger mais avec des
réactions sociales qui sont importantes
là on se rappelle à la fois des gilet
jaune mais les oppositions à la réforme
des retraites aujourd'hui une opposition
qui est latente mais qui est très
présente à sa réforme de l'assurance
chômage
tout ça laisse à penser que c'est à la
fois un emmanuel macron qui veut
convaincre qu'il est toujours un
réformateur mais l'effet est le bilan de
ces cinq ans montre que quand il a
réformé il a aussi beaucoup crispé il a
beaucoup cristallisé il a beaucoup
opposés et que finalement peut-être
kallas
à l'issue de cette pandémie la société
française n'est pas prêtre non plus à
rouvrir certains chantiers elle a
peut-être besoin d'eux
penser la france mais la pensée avec un
a comme avec 1 et donc je me demande si
c'est le bon moment de repartir sur ce
discours
même si je crois qu'il a besoin
d'envoyer des gages à un électorat qui
est le sien et là je pense qu'ils
s'adressent très concrètement un
électorat qui est convaincu qu'il faut
aller au bout des réformes qu'il a
engagées mais la société aujourd'hui
n'est pas dans l'état où elle était en
et aujourd'hui elle est beaucoup plus
impactés fragilisé archipel ise et je ne
sais pas si ce discours va convaincre au
delà de l'électorat qui l'a lui-même à
convaincre mais il endosse la posture je
suis optimiste et je vais réforme est
trop intelligent pour être réductible à
votre étiquette politique mais pour un
socialiste je vous trouve assez
indulgent revoir bienveillant avec le
président on va vous êtes le premier à
le dire c'est bien guillaume roquette il
faudra pour l'interview mais en fait sur
7 quel que puisse dire d'autre il est un
reproche non mais là je ne sais pas ce
que vous voulez comme propos plus
monolithique il pose en réformateur ne
dis pas que ces réformes sont les
bienvenus j'ai dit même que ces réformes
ont crispé la société française et
qu'elles ont même créé dans la société
française des détentions qui sont très
marquantes depuis les gilet jaune les
réformes des retraites est aujourd'hui
la réforme de l'assurance chômage
dire qu'on a une france aujourd'hui qui
est réconcilié en 2021 alors qu'elle ne
l'aurait pas été en 2017 sur cette
partie là du bilan d' emmanuel macron je
suis très critique après les mots ne
sont peut-être pas ce que vous voulez il
ya peut-être développés sont beaucoup
plus forts vont mieux mais voilà mes
mots sont de vous dire que je trouve que
le bilan sur les réformes des manuels
macron n'est pas un bilan aujourd'hui
qui est satisfaisant en termes de revin
de penser une société française
après il a engagé des choses mais
franchement moi je vous le dis je ne
suis pas très convaincu par la méthode
sur ces choses engagé à ce que c'est
cette interview toutes ces grandes idées
qui sont brassés c'est de nature à
convaincre le bloquer ni terre comme
dirait du rhum serbie mari mais puisque
plus que le lectorat populaire à qui ça
risque d'être un étranger
de ce point de vue là je me permettrai à
différents qui reste le point de vue-là
un socialiste un socialiste parisien
c'est à dire que quelqu'un de
fondamentalement très modérée et d'une
qui a voté massivement pour macron lord
à l'élection présidentielle pourquoi
parce que le premier reproche que font
les français à macron n'est pas du tout
un problème de méthode
la question n'est pas du tout un
problème de crispation c'est un problème
d'orientation emmanuel macron fait des
réformes sur lequel il ya des gagnants
et des perdants mais il ya pas mal de
gagnant emmanuel macron et condamnées de
toutes façons a proposé de la réforme ne
peut pas s'asseoir sur un passé de
gauche ou de droite c'est il est
forcément ces quinquas qui est forcément
en mouvement et qui doit promettre des
réformes on s'aperçoit d'ailleurs que ce
bloc élitaire qui l'a mené au pouvoir
pour l'instant restent très soudés
autour de lui emmanuel macron est assez
haut dans les sondages de popularité
40% des sympathisants socialistes
actuels des considère qu'il a un bon
bilan et donc il a effectivement tout
une partie des classes supérieures et
les classes moyennes qui serait très
bien et qui plus est il ya un lien
direct entre les réformes et le co vide
toutes ses dettes qui ont été accumulées
il va falloir les payer en réalité on
peut les payer comment par l'impôt sa
base n'appréciera pas mais on peut les
payer en privatisant un système de
sécurité sociale par exemple on peut les
primes on peut au contraire il est
condamné à aller de l'avant
y compris pour défendre les intérêts de
ceux qui l'ont soutenu et le problème à
mes yeux et aux yeux de beaucoup de
français n'est pas un problème de
méthode ou de crispation ça à preuve le
transfert de propriété
c'est un problème de transfert d'argent
et de modèle de société
le modèle société d' emmanuel macron
était présenté dans son livre révolution
personne n'a été pris par surprise
et désormais il est condamné à
l'amplifier lors de son second mandat il
ya un autre sujet il y en a même
plusieurs autres mais nous avons choisi
de nous arrêter sur un autre thème
développé par le président de la
république et ce n'est pas la première
fois
c'est le sujet de l'histoire et
notamment de l'histoire de la france
comme puissance coloniale je ne suis pas
du tout dans la repentance explique
emmanuel macron mais il veut reconnaître
toutes les parts d'histoire par exemple
autour de la guerre d'algérie les
mémoires brisé humilié irréconciliables
dit-il celle des pieds noirs des harkis
des militaires d appeler les algériens
issus de l'immigration
il faut reconnaître tout sépare de
mémoire et les replacer dans une
histoire commune
ce n'est ni une politique de repentance
mener une politique de déni c'est une
politique de reconnaissance
richard brooks trust un sujet encore une
fois qui qui est régulièrement un traité
par le président de la république on se
souvient du rapport demandé à
l'historien benjamin stora est ce que
vous pensez comme emmanuel macron que
c'est c'est effectivement un noeud là
qu'il ya une espèce de 2,2 d'un pensée
qui empêche la france d'aborder
sereinement l'avenir
moi j'ai enfin sur cette partie de
l'interview d'emmanuel macron et des
passages sur lesquels je me suis
littéralement retrouver je le dis très
très concrètement je pense qu'il manque
des choses d'abord sur votre thématique
vous aviez écrit réécrire l'histoire
le problème n'est pas celle de la
réécriture puisque l'histoire n'est pas
écrite une fois pour toute et figé dans
le marbre
mais en revanche il ya la réinvention
par certains de l'histoire à leur
j'allais dire des concepts qui sont ceux
d'aujourd'hui et qui nous font
réinterpréter et ré inventer une
histoire qui n'a pas lieu d'être en
revanche le fait de mieux comprendre
parce qu'il ya des travaux d'historiens
de chercheurs parce qu'il faut remettre
aussi tout ce qui est nouveau en termes
de ressources et des archives qu'il faut
le réintégrer effectivement et que tous
les pans de l'histoire doivent être
réintégrés dans une histoire collective
et que ça doit aider demain à avoir une
place pour chacun une reconnaissance
pour chacun que ce travail du politique
n'est pas d'écrire cette histoire mais
de permettre que ces sources que
permettre que ce travail sur l'effet sur
le travail des recherches soient mises à
disposition du public et que le public
puisse en avoir y avoir accès je trouve
que ce n'est pas inintéressant
je trouve que le travail qui consiste à
dire qu on réécrit l'histoire
non elle se réécrit parce que les
historiens font un travail régulièrement
qui est celui de revoir cette histoire
est qu'il ya des nouvelles sources et qu
on a aujourd'hui des points de vue ont
parlé l'histoire du moyen âge mais
l'histoire du moyen-âge aujourd'hui
n'est pas celle qu'on a enseigné à mes
parents qui voyait le moyen-âge comme
étant un temps obscurs et aujourd'hui on
s'aperçoit que c'est un temps un petit
peu différent et que des gens
favier et ses goûts var ont peut-être
remis l'histoire du moyen-âge sur un
autre pied et c'est vrai aussi pour
l'histoire plus récente et l'histoire
coloniale ou des éléments aujourd'hui
viennent donner à voir ce que l'on ne
connaissait pas forcément à une époque
où on a écrit une histoire de cette voie
là elle moi je pensais pourtant ce
travail de redonner aux histoires rien
la possibilité de le poursuivre ce
travail et aux politiques aussi pas de
le mettre en scène enfin le musée de
l'histoire de l'immigration aujourd'hui
je ne sais pas si on avait exactement le
même
il ya 50 ans les documents les
manifestations qui sont exposés montrer
témoigne d'évolution et de ce secteur
qu'on voit la con con revisités comme on
apprend je trouve que ce n'est pas
inintéressant
encore une fois avec l'idée de ne pas
réinventer l'histoire
je vous sens modérément enthousiaste à
3-2 alors totale pour tout simplement
parce que mais ce n'était pas top elle
socialise parisien qui parle là sur ce
coup là maintenant surtout l'historien
en l'occurrence non me concerne pour
vous parce que c'est il ya deux parties
dans son développement sur l'histoire et
je trouve qu'il est beaucoup plus
convaincant et par la géographie
française on croit lire du jean pierre
le goff en croit lire du crestor oui
c'est très très bien sûr l'histoire
c'est absolument lamentable il faut dire
les choses comme elles sont il ya deux
parties une partie sur la mémoire de la
période de l'occupation et il ya une
partie sur la guerre d'algérie et les
guerres coloniales ont déjà sur
l'occupation
emmanuel macron dit n'importe quoi vous
dire les choses clairement il raconte il
rentre dans le cliché selon lequel on
serait prisonnier d'une histoire
résistance y'a liste alors d'excellence
historiens que je vous conseille pierre
laborie qui est décédé récemment avait
écrit notamment le chagrin et venant il
montré le mythe de cette histoire rester
en statu élites que moi 55 ans on ne m'a
jamais enseigné
ça fait plus de 40 ans enfin depuis
toujours on en parle énormément de la
collaboration on parle énormément
on n'a jamais enseigné aux enfants
français en tout cas depuis les au cours
dernières décennies que les français
avaient toujours été résistant je crois
que ça n'a jamais été enseigné pour
préciser un vote négatif
il décrit donc je vous laisse sur
l'attitude sur la dune
général de gaulle expliquant à la
libération que la france a été libéré
par elle-même et emmanuel macron ajoute
il nous a fallu des décennies pour
reconnaître notre responsabilité dans la
rafle des juifs parce que nous savons
tous que les français n'ont pas été que
des maquisards
mais c'est entièrement faux ce qu'il
raconte effectivement il fait allusion
au discours à l'hôtel de ville du
général de gaulle
ce discours très lyrique auquel personne
ne croit en réalité même sur place ce
qu'on va bien tout posséder aucune
américains ont débarqué et c est par
ailleurs effectivement le riz socialisme
a peut-être existé au début de la vème
république
mais en tout cas moi qui suis quand même
pas tout jeune je n'ai jamais connu
pierre laborie encore une fois en
justice
ça fait juste il de 7,7 ce mythe il ya
également un nouveau nexans ouvrage de
françois azouvi qui vient de sortir chez
gallimard
et qui dit s'appelle français on ne vous
a rien caché la résistance vichy notre
mémoire
c'est osé cnrf françoise ou 10 et qui
aussi montre bien de manière très
précise que ni dans les manuels des
discours ce discours est ancienne a été
tenue donc parmi ces points la seconde
c'est un mythe l'entretien est sûr que
colony alors là il faut distinguer trois
niveaux d'histoire il ya l'histoire que
l'on commémore l'histoire que l'on
enseigne et enfin la recherche
historique sur la recherche historique
dans la limite de temporel vous savez
qu'on se fixe comme tous sont toutes les
périodes et bien la recherche historique
a toujours été extrêmement libre sur la
guerre la colonisation c'est les
archives qui sont à aix-en-provence
c'était le métier de mon père par
ailleurs et je peux vous dire que jamais
sauf pour des raisons de secret défense
etc
il ya eu de problème particulier les
bouquins d'yves courrière trois gars
jerry des quatre tomes vous savez sont
contestés d'ailleurs mais c'est ça a été
écrit il ya 50 ans là dessus on sait
tous reconnais les massacres de part et
d'autre et c'est depuis toujours
après il ya l'histoire qu'on enseigne on
enseignait pas la guerre à l'algérie
parce que c'était trop proche maintenant
on peint on traite l'histoire coloniale
dans les manuels et enfin il ya
l'histoire qu'on commémore et là
effectivement on peut pas demander à un
pays de commémorer forcément uniquement
contre lui-même comme on a tendance à le
faire après il ouvre la boîte de pandore
parce qu'il va falloir tout d'enseigner
est ce qu'il est véritablement la
recherche historique c'est un non sujet
tout le monde tout le monde peut faire
les recharges qui veut donc là aucun
problème et depuis des décennies là
aussi sur l'histoire qu'on enseigne au
lycée
arles est ce que il faut il est sain
pour le pays de uniquement dans les
crimes etc
lui-même ne parle que d esclavage ne
parle qu'une chose comme ça c'est
extrêmement contestable et pour la
guerre en algérie en particulier là il
ya un projet très précis avec benjamin
stora est ce qu'il est vraiment sage de
se raconter et de raconter de passer
notre temps à se raconter les massacres
croisés parce que si on parle du 8 mai
45 de ce qui s'est passé à kénitra
guelma et sétif
eh bien on va parler du 5 juillet 62 à
oran on va parler des massacres de
melouza du fln contre les messalistes et
on peut continuer comme ça donc ce ne
serait plus qu'une histoire de massacres
de tortures et d'enlèvement de part et
d'autre d'expropriation de part et
d'autre et on aura gagné quoi exactement
c'est quoi l'intérêt si les gens veulent
s'intéresser à l'histoire
ils peuvent aller chercher les livres
les bibliothèques les librairies sont
plein de bouquins d'histoire rien soit
garée chéri de pas écrit avec des points
de vue très différents
inversement je ne vois pas l'intérêt
actuellement de cette fixation
obsessionnelle sur ce qui nous divise le
plus alors beaucoup de réactions sur ce
sur ce thème notamment à ce verbe que
nous avons choisi réécrire d'henri
symbolique soulignait non sans raison
que il était un peu de parti pris mais
après tout c'est aussi ça point de vue
après la colonisation faut-il réécrire
notre histoire et vous répondez non sur
twitter à 85%
le roman des colonials est un danger
c'est la première pierre de la
déconstruction de la france en tant que
nation nous dit général escape ou escape
je ne sais pas si c'est un général
américain
la bille sur youtube où il faut réécrire
l'histoire car il ya plein de passages
écrits par des partisans d'idéologie
nocives
ce n'est pas la peine de perpétuer des
mythes faux marque sur youtube vouloir
occulter se passer car il ne correspond
pas à nos valeurs actuelles prouve bien
que l'on vit une période trouble que nos
dirigeants veulent faire table rase
ce qui prouve qu'ils ont peur de
l'avenir et puis une autre sur le site
du figaro pour comprendre l'histoire
collective
il faudrait que l'enseignement soit
effectuée en ce sens
richard bouhet moi je voulais vous
livrer un point de vue je pense que
c'est très dangereux de vouloir en
particulier se replonger dans cette
histoire de la guerre d'algérie parce
que ça ne peut faire que accentuer le le
mal être d'une partie des français
d'origine algérienne qui vivent très mal
le fait qu' ils ont senti mans 2-2
qui est un pays qui était leur
adversaire voir l'heure et demie la
france et que maintenant ils vivent dans
ce pays qui n'en développe une espèce de
culpabilité qui ne peut que produire des
choses négatives et que donc mais c'est
mon point de vue au moins on en parle
mieux c'est mais c'est votre train du
million broquères les acteurs sans doute
je trouve que c'est je trouve que c'est
radical encore une fois on est sur des
sujets qui sont quand même des sujets
difficiles
enfin on va pas dire que ces sujets là
est un sujet facile et on sait notamment
sur la guerre d'algérie fin je ne les ai
pas fait mon père a fait la guerre
d'algérie je sais ce qu il en a ramené
comme à la fois souvenirs douloureux
comme silence gêné et comme à un moment
donné propos régulièrement ressasser
dans des conversations par bribes comme
s'il fallait lâcher des choses tu as un
moment donné n'était pas lâcher et qu'il
n'entendait pas par ailleurs alors qu'en
gros il ne s'est jamais reconnu lui dans
ce qu on a véritablement raconter sa
guerre d'algérie entre guillemets n'a
jamais recoller à ce qu'il a entendu
raconter sur la guerre d'algérie je ne
dis pas qu'il n'ya pas eu plein de
choses de raconter jeudi qu'il ne s'est
pas retrouvé dans les discours il se
retrouve maintenant dans des propos et
dans des documentaires où il voit des
pleins de partie on vous dit pas ça je
me retrouve là dedans et c'est pas
exactement où je me retrouvais pas ce
que c'était une histoire récente parce
que c'était une histoire qui était dur à
sortir et ils s'y retrouvent bien plus
tard mais je pense que le fait qu'il s'y
retrouve veut dire qu'il ya des mômes
lie à des mémoires qui à un moment donné
comment ça se recoller à tout ça je ne
pense pas que ce soit une mauvaise
approche
encore une fois tout dépend moi je pense
que tout dépend ce qu'on veut en faire
de ça si c'est pour un dessein politique
qui serait de dire peur de l'avenir on
se replonge dans des cicatrices du passé
on pense qu'on se replongeant dans les
cicatrices du passé on va résoudre des
problèmes d'aujourd'hui
je pense que c'est nous c'est vraiment
une manière d'approcher les choses qui
est maladroite parce que ça ne se passe
pas comme ça mais si c'est permettre par
moments de recoller ses mémoires pour
pourquoi pas j'ai franchement je vais
vous pensez qu'on peut sceller recoller
ben moi je verrais apaisé bah je sais je
pense que à un moment donné le temps le
temps et là aussi enfin ce qu'on disait
en 1965 mais pas exactement ce qu'on dit
en 2021
c'est ce que l'on
après par exemple enfin c'est reçu en
tout cas 20 mois voilà je prends des
exemples après on n'est pas d'accord sur
ça avec leur mieux c'est pour cela et
donc moi je pense que dire qu'à un
moment donné on ne recolle parent que
chacun ne se retrouve pas dans une
histoire telle qu'elle a pu être raconté
par les uns ou par les autres je ne dis
pas je pense que c'est mieux que chacun
s'y retrouve s'y retrouver il couvre une
place ils trouvent quelque chose qui a
été de 2 de son passage et de son
expérience mais c'est vraiment ce que je
le pensais mais je crois qu'on en touche
et un problème ontologique sur ce qu'on
veut faire de l'histoire
l'histoire s'est pas réconcilié les gens
l'histoire ce n'est pas faire du bien
aux gens leur dire qu'ils ont eu raison
et les mais au moins ils auront beaucoup
souffert l'histoire c'est la recherche
de la vérité de la recherche de vérité
factuelle
donc on enseigne l'histoire bien sûr
qu'on va lui enseigner l'histoire de la
guerre d'algérie
à mon avis plus ça sera factuel bien ce
sera moins il y aura de commentaires
mieux ce sera on peut la recherche
historique lalieux et vous serez
meilleurs on a toujours excuser moi se
souvenir personnel j'ai passé le n s
sans succès malheureusement en 1985
emmanuel macron non plus enfin si
joliment vers la porte et de réussir
dans l'année donc c'était pas et notre
sujet en histoire justement moi cette
option histoire notre sujet c'est l
empire colonial et notamment la guerre
d'algérie donc on a toujours enseigné ce
à tous les niveaux
on a toujours eu tous les documents à
tous les niveaux où c'est tout soit il
est l'égérie bien simple et on sait tous
depuis très longtemps le seul problème
condat ses archives algériennes en
réalité mais les archives françaises
sont ouvertes et sert on sait tous
absolument donc au niveau de la
recherche historique après il faut
l'enseigner factuellement et il faut
sortir de cette confusion maladive
entre histoire et mémoire la mémoire ce
n'est pas la vérité
la mémoire c'est chaque communauté
chaque groupe humain où chaque individu
qui se raconte qu'il a eu raison et
qu'il a beaucoup souffert contrairement
aux autres les mémoires sont par nature
irréconciliables parce que la mémoire
c'est sert à se justifier ça serve pas à
chercher la vérité vouloir réconcilier
mémoire c'est entretenir les conflits
les mémoires sont différentes elles
resteront différentes vous n'aurez pas
la même mémoire pourra rapatrier à nice
que pour quelqu'un qui est issu de d'une
famille qui a combattu contre la france
en algérie
c'est normal c'est normal c'est humain
on a tous nos mémoires même le sol on
nous abandonne et donc l'histoire n'a
pas à s'occuper de ça elle n'a pas
cherché à justifier les ans ou
sol et les autres elle a juste à dire ce
qui s'est réellement passé un mot de
conclusion et je n'en verrai facilier
recoller les mémoires c'est pas la même
chose mais ça sera votre mot de la fin
merci beaucoup à tous les deux merci à
vous de nous avoir l'arrivée
donc nous avons évoqué cette interview
du président de la république aux
trimestriels
zadig merci à tous et point de vue
revient demain à la même heure et au
même endroit bonsoir
[Musique]